meantime there are now fewer than 45
days until the midterm elections in
November and that will decide which
party controls Congress according to the
latest CBS News you gov Battleground
tracker the estimates still hold that
Republicans are going to win a majority
but their margin continues to shrink the
newest estimate shows them taking 223
seats that is down from August
projection but it still puts them over
the 218 needed to win control CBS News
elections and surveys director Anthony
silvanto is here Anthony good morning to
you uh good morning this is a big shift
if you go back even to July why is the
margin for Republicans shrinking it is
shrinking largely because of the
abortion issue and that speaks to what
is this a campaign about let me set this
up among women to get your vote a
candidate has to agree with you on
abortion is a top thing it's even higher
than the economy that's number one and
then you look at well who's winning the
votes of people that think abortion is
important and they're breaking
Democratic and increasingly so Tony over
the last month now set that up against
the people who say the economy is
important they're still breaking towards
the Republicans and that's really big
and that's why the Republicans still
have the lead but the abortion issue is
why it's gotten tighter abortion is a
rights issue for Democrats but there are
rights issues on the Republican side as
well are there not there are indeed and
in fact let me show you this when we ask
people what do you think is at stake
here it's your rights and freedoms that
goes to the top even more so than your
financial well-being so for both sides
you see this like escalation of what the
stakes are in this campaign rights and
freedoms for Americans there's also this
question of who gets to be an American
we've got all these encounters on the
southern border and Republicans want to
make an issue out of immigration is that
having an effect on the race yeah it is
start with this among Republicans and in
their base this is important because
there's a turnout election right you
want to motivate your base well
Republicans really like the idea of
Republican Governor sending immigrants
to democratic areas that's just 87 and
then they think it's good because it
puts the issue on the radar highlights
the problem right well that's doing that
in some respects because you look at the
people who think immigration is
important in their vote and that's gone
up it's gone up to 86 percent among
Republicans it's gone up to 57 percent
up from 50 among Independents so putting
it on the radar a little bit all right
Anthony savants are really great
information appreciate it